and now it's time for bombing reviews
with Chester a bum
tonight's review greatest movie I've
ever seen in my life
Toby says there are spoilers dears this
family who lives in the 80s and it turns
out in the future one of the little
girls is gonna grow up in her house is
gonna be robbed but nothing's gonna be
stolen except for a necklace
oh and apparently some tapes don't
remember that from the next movie but
this movie clarifies that that's what
happened tapes were stolen as well
that's why all throughout the second
film they always said wasn't it weirder
please being broken into and nothing
being stolen except our tapes I mean I
find that very weird that he would only
take our tanks I'm questioning that you
know as it started discussion it's not
like this was written later so we can
move the story along more conveniently
oh yeah by the way Anakin Skywalker bill
c-3po so the family is living really
really happily but they have one little
problem their grandparents promised
their very first son to the devil I
promised my firstborn son to the devil
Wes and yet I still can't get pregnant
but it's okay because these ghosts are
talking to the two little girls
oh come on McGuire you've been dead if
it's in spider-man 3 I know I'm a bitch
and so the stepfather think something
weird is going on and so we start
setting up cameras all throughout the
house I'm just hitting up a camera in
the kids room so I can watch them all
night even though you're new to this
family I won't find this weed and see
how I'm the only male in the Paranormal
Activity movie I'm just gonna be a
jackass and a moron
Fuzzy's fair so he sets up cameras all
around the house and guess what he
discovers everyone in the house scares
the babies just some supernatural entity
pulling my daughter's hair so the ghost
starts using things around the house to
scare them including hiding himself
under a sheet I get it lag raising the
kitchen table to time and even using the
light bright light bright light bright
Saint is watching you too now
first a father is like totally freaked
out I think we should get out of here
and the mother is like go to Grandma's
house and the grandmothers like honey
you'll be safe and sound in my cult what
cooked what living room okay the
stepfather and mother think that your
sounded them another night and because
this that father likes to freaking film
everything he tastes the camera around
the house to look at the intruders and
what does he find
but the stepfather finds one of the
doctors and they hide in the closet you
know got her stupid stepfather girl
breathing heavily as she's almost scared
to death cool this is a great idea tube
in twenty years but then he comes across
this other little daughter standing
there by the body of its dead white
poster fathers like you stay here my
daughter while I go check on your sister
yes so they won't expect it if we split
up you're a horrible father I'm glad
you're gonna die so the particles over
to the other little daughter and slowly
and it's breaking possible no rush at
all guy there's just a whole team of
psychotic killers looking for you and
the daughter is like girls in the
grandma and the grandmas like can meet a
garis we have a wedding to get to
they tied up everything nicely except
for the fact that there's about a
bajillion unanswered questions for the
little girl's marrying a ghost
what does marrying a ghost have to do
with giving birth to a son why don't
they remember any of this in the other
movies why were the girls suddenly okay
with this well all these questions and
more will be answered in paranormal
activity for still milking it pray now
something you might be wondering is why
I hadn't mentioned the fact that there's
a scary Teddy Ruxpin in the movie well
it's not like Teddy Ruxpin is an actual
real threat or alive right now are
pointing a gun at me in the least in
fact it was probably a mistake to
mention him at all